and I've wasted a lot of time just being
angry people I don't know you know it's
amazing how nasty we can get is people
depending on this situation like most
people are okay
as long as they are okay but if you put
people in certain contexts they just
change like when I'm in my car I have a
different set of values I am the worst
person I can be when I'm behind the
wheel which is when I'm at my most
dangerous when you're driving that's
when you need to be the most
compassionate and responsible of any
other time in your life because you are
[ __ ] driving a weapon amongst weapons
and yet it's the worst people get and I
am the worst one time I was driving and
there was a guy ahead of me and he kinda
I don't know he sort of drifted into my
lane for a second and this came out of
my mouth I said worthless piece of [ __ ]
what an indictment what kind of a way is
that to feel about another human being
worthless pieces [ __ ] that's somebody's
son and things have said to the people I
wasn't once driving some guy in a pickup
truck - I don't know remember even and I
yelled out my window yay I said hey [ __ ]
you
we're outside of a car is that even
nearly okay if you're in an elevator and
you are like right next to a person's
body and whatever like he leaned into
you a little bit would you ever turn
right to their face you know hey [ __ ]
you
[Applause]
worthless pieces [ __ ]
no literally zero people would ever do
that but put a couple of pieces of glass
and some road between yet there's
nothing you would not say to them I hope
you die I said that to a person I hope
you die why cuz you made me go like this
for half a second of my life
you tested my reflexes and it worked out
fine
so now I hope your kids grow up
motherless I mean what am i capable of
I'd like to think that I'm a nice person
but I don't know man a lot of it is
context
there's a lot of things I wonder if the
world was different like if murder was
legal I might have killed a few people I
don't know I'd love to think oh I would
never do that
but we really need the law against
murder for one simple reason the law
against murder is the number one thing
preventing murder we'd like to think
it's because like oh I would never do
that no it's cuz it really sucks getting
caught murdering a lot if murder was
legal or just a misdemeanor like you get
a thing in the mail a [ __ ] they had a
camera there now when people make fun of
me I deserve it I do when people get mad
at me now it's it's my father will get
mad at me on the highway that's all my
bad I'm a terrible driver I know nothing
about cars
I meant to learn about cars and then I
forgot I'm nothing that I know can help
you with your car ever unless you're
like hey I've got a flat tire does
anyone here know a lot about The Cosby
Show and then Oh perhaps I could be of
some assistance I'm one of the worst
drivers I've ever seen and I just want
you all to know that if you're ever on
the highway behind me uh I hear you
honking and I also don't want me to be
doing what I'm doing
I don't like that I'm in that Lane
either and I sure would like to get out
of it I was on the highway in Texas
recently which was like a highway filled
with 13 year olds and I was in the far
left lane and I was going in the far
left lane and then it turned into a
u-turn only lane and I started to make a
u-turn but then I panicked cuz I didn't
want to make a u-turn so I put the car
in reverse and then merged right back
onto the highway the best thing about
that was that after that cars were
pulling up and looking over to see who
just did that piece of [ __ ] move
expecting to see like a hundred year old
blind dog who's texting while driving
and drinking a smoothie and said they
see a 28 year old healthy man trying his
best and they're a couple things about
me you ought to know first
I Drive kind of recklessly I take a lot
of chances I never repair my vehicles
and I don't believe in traffic laws
so I tend to have quite a high number of
traffic accidents and last week I either
ran over a sheep or I ran over a small
man wearing a sheepskin coat and I don't
know because I didn't stop I do not stop
when I have a traffic accident do you
know you can't hey who has time
not me I hit somebody I run somebody
over it's I keep moving especially if
I've injured someone I do not get
involved in that I'm not a doctor I've
had no medical training I'm just another
guy out driving around looking for
little fun and I can't be stopping for
everything well let's just look at it
logically let's be logical about it if
you do stop at the scene of the accident
all you do is add to the confusion these
people you ran over have enough troubles
of their own without you stopping and
making things worse leave these people
alone
they've just been in a major traffic
accident the last thing they need is for
you to stop and get out of your car and
go over to the fire because by now it is
a fire let's start bothering them with a
lot of stupid questions are you hurt
well of course they're hurt look at all
the blood
you just ran over them a ton and a half
of Steel of course they're hurt leave
these people alone haven't you done
enough for once in your life do the
decent thing don't get involved well in
the first place it's none of your
business none of your business the whole
thing took place outside of your car
legally speaking these people you ran
over were not on your property at the
time you ran them over they were
standing in the street that is city
property you are not responsible if they
don't like it let them sue the city and
besides it happened back there it's over
now stop living in the past
do yourself a favor count your blessings
be glad it wasn't you then I'll give you
a practical reason not to stop you need
a practical reason if you do stop sooner
or later the police are gonna show up is
that what you want
huh waste even more of your time
standing around filling out forms
answering a lot of foolish questions
lying to the authorities and by the way
who are you to be taking up the valuable
time of the police department these men
and women are professionals they're
supposed to be out fighting crime stop
interfering with police and besides
didn't anyone else see this accident are
you the only one who can provide
information sure did the people he ran
over caught a glimpse of it at the last
moment so let them tell the police what
happened there are a lot closer to it
than you were
there's no sense having two conflicting
stories floating around about the same
dumbass traffic accident things are bad
enough people are dead families have
been destroyed time to get moving now on
the other hand on the other hand if I
should be out driving around looking for
a little fun and I see an accident one
that I'm not involved in I stop
immediately
well I want to get a good look at what's
going on I enjoy that sort of thing
someone else is injured I want to take a
look I am Curious George
but people don't like that police don't
like it they say you rubberneck and they
say you're blocking traffic never mind
that [ __ ] I want to take a look I'm
never too busy that I can't stop to
enjoy someone else's suffering and I'll
tell you something else I'm a big fan of
traffic accidents you know my favorite
accident two buses and a chicken truck
get hit by a circus train in front of a
flea market well I want to see something
interesting I'm looking for a neck
sticking out of a gas tank if I'm gonna
take the time to stop I expect a couple
of [ __ ] laughs
and if my car should happen to be in
such a position where I can't quite see
what's going on can't get a good enough
look I'm not the least bit shy about
asking the police to bring the bodies
over a little closer to the car pardon
me officer would you fellows mind
dragging that twisted looking chap over
here there closer to the car please my
wife has never seen anyone shaped quite
like that
look at that sugar lips that's his
ribcage sticking out of the glove
compartment Thank You officer that will
be all now you can throw him back on the
pile we'll be moving along and off I go
out onto the highway looking for a
little fun
perhaps a tanker truck filled with human
waste will explode in front of the
Pokemon Factory I'm joking around I'm
making fun of people falling and old
people stuff but I can do that you know
why because I have old people in my life
that I'm close to my role manners and I
are very close he's older so we fight a
lot though you know it's kind of like a
relationship been around me for years he
was with me before money even came into
the picture he's the one scrambling up
for me but when you around somebody for
so long
naturally you start to butt heads Lydia
should annoy you I don't like the way he
sneezes I don't like him like I swing
out when he sneeze it's like it's a
close call like you think he's about to
die yes I sneeze I'm not boys just the
scariest [ __ ] I've ever heard of my life
I never seen nobody can't say breath
from a sneeze he's Aldo man because so
much [ __ ] to pissing me off like I'm one
thing man I don't like it when people
are slow he's very slow when you getting
the car how long does it take you to
pull off man when you get in the car a
couple seconds right okay
took him 25 minutes to pull off the
other day I miss it I can't I can't I
can't show you I can't tell you I got to
show you but don't make me laugh
okay I'll show you exactly what he did
okay I'm in a car I'm in a passenger
seat I got my seat bud on I'm ready for
him all you gotta do is get in the car
pull off i'ma show you exactly what he
did don't make me laugh though
[Music]
yes
oh okay hey hey hey Kevin
hey Kevin hey Kevin thanks hey Jenny
look what it
now I don't want to laugh cuz I want to
see what he's gonna say about taking
some all right I'm taking this exactly
did I my [ __ ] Oh God alright you
ready you ready good on that here yes
like I'm waiting on you come on this is
[ __ ] to piss me off he's alright let's
go what what the [ __ ] is this why are
you shooting at me that [ __ ] made me so
mad what the [ __ ] don't do that don't
put your hands in my face cuz you're
being an [ __ ] just drive man don't
say [ __ ] to me just drive the car